c'est devant leur écran respectifs que
les dirigeants se donnent rendez vous
pour le g20 cette année et pour la
première fois
l'arabie saoudite préside le sommet
cette pandémie nous a démontré que la
coopération internationale est
nécessaire pour traverser les crises a
dit en ouverture le prince héritier
mohammed bin salman
la réunion se tient sur fond de crise
sanitaire et économique d'une pandémie
d'une ampleur historique plus de 55
millions de personnes ont contracté la
maladie à travers le monde plus d'un
million trois cent mille personnes en
sont mortes
devant l'ampleur du problème un enjeu
l'accessibilité ou futurs vaccins notre
mobilisation doit donc veiller aussi à
ce que dès que des traitements contre le
virus se stabilise il puisse être de la
même manière
diffuser partager avec les pays les plus
pauvres et les économies en
développement ont dit palmire heinze ou
de l'accès à la vaccination doit être
possible dans chaque pays
les fonds promis jusqu'à présent ne sont
pas encore suffisants pour y parvenir
affirme la chancelière allemande qui
demandent aux pays du g20 de financer
davantage l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
le premier ministre italien qui gère une
multiplication des cas dans son pays
avec près de quarante mille personnes
infectées en 24 heures insiste l'ampleur
du défi pour les dirigeants sommés l'été
nous avons la responsabilité et le
devoir de trouver une solution pour
gérer cette crise pour les générations
futures at-il dit mme aubry
nous allons travailler avec la
communauté internationale pour trouver
un vaccin arrêter cette pandémie affirme
pour sa part le président de la corée du
sud
jusqu'à présent plus de 21 milliards de
dollars ont été dépensés par les pays du
g20 pour combattre le coronavirus il se
marie michel lauzon radio-canada à
montréal